but think about an average like 55 year
old woman that you know wearing a
swimsuit like this it's almost like
we're living in this La La Land like I'm
sorry 55 year old woman should not be
moving like a 25 year old woman this
should not be controversial I don't care
if you're single or married you're
supposed to be an example to the younger
women yet like I don't even wear
swimsuits like that and I'm half your
age lady like and this is the crazy
thing it's like we have all of these old
ladies living like they're 25 when they
are not and we have a society that
pushes them to live in this delusion
when literally this woman is at the end
of her life you know I mean she's gonna
maybe make it to like 70 75 80. and what
is that what does the end of life look
like